can we address the phenomenon of hat
taking pretty girls at bars flirting
with you bite taking your head please
don't take it I mean that you take that
hat I look like a goofball in front of
you and I just want to go home okay
there's another one when girls hit you
and they to get your attention or
there's a playful element of like a
little lakeshore I'm not saying I get
hurt but I feel like patting my head
there's a specific way you have to do it
with the grain I'm a man I want to feel
like a man like I'm here to like your
head on you and if you're like yeah it's
like firm on me Joshy that my mom calls
me Joshy I'm thinking about my mom now
it's always I can eat it's like a cutie
little thing that doesn't bother me
that's my card that I play all the time
is the cute funny guy dime misconstrue
the situation women in general are
confusing when a girl tells me let's get
lunch
so was that we not no guy I know brags
about how many lunches he goes on at the
end of the day though if I like you and
you're talking to me you probably get
away with a lot